monsieur bonsoir cette fois ci elle est
partie et à l'heure prévue à 14h heure
française cet après midi la première
navette spatiale américaine piloté par
crippen des young a décollé sans
problème vous avez pu suivre cet
événement sur antenne 2 en direct avec
cet exploit georges leclercq l'humanité
à renouer avec la grande aventure
spatiale le jour même où l'on fête le
vingtième anniversaire du premier vol du
russe youri gagarine
et oui elle est partie depuis deux ans
les américains attendaient ce moment le
retour en force de leur pays dans la
conquête de l'espace
cette navette c'est une extraordinaire
réussite du point de vue technique et
aussi du point de vue humain c'est
l'accès au cosmos pour tout le monde ou
presque puisqu'il ne faudra plus
d'entraînement très poussée pour
travailler en orbite terrestre
en attendant il faut quand même la
mettre au point cette navette est pour
cela deux pilotes chevronnés
john young et bob crippen trouve aux
commandes voici un des passages les plus
redoutés cette phase deux minutes après
le décollage les deux fusées latéral à
poudre les premières jamais employer
pour un volume 1 vont se détacher leur
carburant épuisé regardez maintenant
nous sommes en orbite autour de la terre
les diverses caméra de la navette nous
montre les portes et les radiateurs
vous remonterez sur la petite claque et
c'est ici la kz2 visée des caméras
la première vise ici vous avez vu le
coin de la porte avec la cabine avant
c'est ici vous voyez il ya d'autres
caméras
maintenant regardez sur l'image vous
allez voir un autre axe c'est l'arrière
les astronautes regarde vers la queue et
découvre avec effroi que quelques tuiles
de la protection thermique autour des
moteurs ont été arrachés tellement le
décollage et la mise en orbite ont été
violentes
ce qui inquiète la nasa ce sont les
taches noires là que vous voyez où il y
manque des tuiles fébrilement la caméra
recherche partout d'autres traces
sombres car la mission peut être
sérieusement compromise si trop de
tuiles ont été arrachées
puis c'est l'observation de la dérive
c'est à dire la queue ici vous allez la
voir là heureusement toutes les tuiles
en tenue voici la dérive
la caméra joue le sien les télécommandes
et depuis houston la zone blanche que
vous avez découvertes au dessus de là
que c'est la terre car pour cette
mission la navette vols allant vers la
tête en bas en face on peut dire jusque
dans l'espace n'y a ni eau ni bas vous
avez peut-être vu quelques pièces
détachées une petite rondelle qui
passent ici à travers la soute des
rondelles des fragments des débris mais
après examen la nasa rend son verdict
il n'y aura pas besoin de sortie dans
l'espace hors du véhicule pour réparer
donc les astronautes peuvent se mettre
en manche de chemise et continuer leur
vérification de la navette missions
essentielles et a dit georges dia compte
tenu des incidents qui ont eu lieu quels
sont les principaux obstacles à la
revenu sur terre bon alors là le retour
se passe mardi soir à 20h30
premier obstacle la navette va passer de
28 mille kilomètres à l'heure autour de
la terre à quelques centaines seulement
moment de l'atterrissage voyez donc un
freinage considérable qui va échauffés
énormément les tuiles la protection
thermique en dessous qui va être portée
donc à 1500 degrés
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait une
inquiétude heureusement les tuiles qui
manquent sont plutôt ici
là on aura 300 400 degrés la nasa n'a
pas jugé bon de tenter de les réparer
ensuite vous avez un autre fait la
navette n'a plus de moteur plutôt n'a
plus de carburant pour les faire
fonctionner elle arrive comme un planeur
et n'aura pas de deuxième chance si elle
rate la piste c'est l'écrasement
voyez donc l'importance des ordinateurs
de bord qui ont motivé le report de deux
jours pour piloter cette navette est là
mais dans la bonne position pour se
poser mardi soir nous vous ferons vivre
la plupart des événements importants de
cette navette comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure à 14 heures
avec le décollage en direct sur antenne
2 et ça depuis le début de cette mission
historique vient si georges nous
resterons d'ailleurs dans l'espace
demain à midi puisque l'invité d'antenne
dès midi je vous signale tout de suite
sera monsieur antoine labeyrie qui est
astronome et qui dirige l'observatoire
de grâce un autre exploit bien sur terre
celui là et même sur les pavés du nord
bernard hinault a remporté cet après
midi paris roubaix cette grande
classique française que l'on croyait
pourtant réservée aux coureurs belges ou
hollandais puisque le dernier français à
l'avoir gagné était louison bobet
il y à 25 ans christine parisse
à 12 km de l'arrivée sur les pavés dans
un virage bernard hinault chute tout
comme l'avait fait duclos-lassalle
auparavant mais contrairement à duclos
lassalle et nous on se relèvera vite et
parvient à revenir dans le peloton de
tête
il reprendra même en quelques minutes la
tête de l'échappée constitué par les
belges de vlaeminck demeyer van calster
le néerlandais kuipers l'italien moser
hinault a très bien préparé la course le
champion du monde pourtant n'aime guère
paris-roubaix 80 kilomètres de pavés les
ornières la boue et la chute comme nous
venons de le voir un kilomètre de
l'arrivée cuyper passe en tête mais il
n'est pas loin
six hommes peuvent encore gagner moser
veut surtout rééditer sa victoire de
l'an passé
dernier tour sur le vélodrome de roubaix
hinault et devant 203 kilomètres
parcourus mais le français ne se désunit
pas il a décidé de mener le 5
il se sent très fort capable de résister
au retour de ses compagnons regardez le
sprint final une victoire française
un quart de siècle après celle de
louison bobet temps dinan 6h26 700e
deuxième de vlaeminck troisième moser
quatrième van calster même temps une
grande victoire dans une course
impitoyable
il a gagné maintenant l'arrivée du grand
prix d'argentine automobile qui vient de
se terminer à quelques instants le
premier nelson piquet est sur brabham
deuxième rothmans l'argentin sur
williams 3e proche plus sur renault
c'est la première fois que le conseil
pour le podium et 5e arnoux sur renault
également un bon score malgré tout pour
les français dans cette course dans ce
grand prix d'argent
la campagne présidentielle commence
demain officiellement à la radio et à la
télévision le tirage au sort de l'ordre
d'apparition des candidats eu lieu ce
matin au conseil d'état lauren cuse en
principe pendant la campagne officielle
chaque candidat dispose de deux heures
télévisés et deux heures à la radio
nationale
la commission nationale de contrôle peut
réduire ce temps s'il ya trop de
candidats
en 1974 elle l'a réduit à 1h05 à la
radio 1h05 à la télévision cette année
le temps et de 1h10 répartis entre le
midi et le soir
ce matin pour le tirage au sort de
l'ordre de passage chaque candidat a été
représenté par une personnalité le
soutenant demain soir tous les candidats
auront cinq minutes à tour de rôle pour
se présenter dans l'ordre messieurs
marchait debré madame bouchardeau mais
sur la londe chirac mallet mme laguiller
messieurs mitterrand treppoz giscard
d'estaing et madame garot ils auront
cinq minutes le 24 avril au soir pour
complot ils interviendront après les
journaux télévisés qui seront diffusés
35 minutes avant l'heure habituelle les
missions de la campagne se déroule en
différé car la commission doit pouvoir
contrôler le contenu et la dignité des
interventions de chacun la grille
horaire des passages a été établi de
façon à assurer à chacun une parfaite
égalité d'audience entre le midi et le
soir
vu le parti communiste a profité de ce
tirage au sort pour protester contre la
réduction de deux heures à 1h10 du temps
de passage des candidats pendant cette
campagne officielle monsieur giscard
d'estaing était ce soir l'invité du club
de la presse d'europe numéro 1 il a
répondu dans un premier temps à une
question sur les divisions de la
majorité
monsieur giscard d'estaing on veut faire
croire qu'il y a un problème d'unité du
côté de la majorité et je vous dirais
franchement je ne le crois pas il ya
naturellement les secousses et
turbulences d'une campagne
présidentielle qui sont fortes et fait
d'ailleurs à mes yeux compréhensible
mais la majorité d'où vient-elle
c'est la majorité de 1978 dans laquelle
il a eu un contrat entre des électeurs
et des élus qui étaient les députés
d'arrondissement
si je suis réélu au mois de mai il y
aura à nouveau une expression majorie
r et pensez vous que les élus qui ont un
contrat avec leurs électeurs datant de
60 18 contrats qui reposait sur l'unité
de la majorité et parfois même sur
l'unité de candidature vous avez parmi
les personnages importants de la
majorité dans les différentes parties
des hommes qui ont été les candidats
uniques en 1978 qui d'enquêté ont été
lus par la totalité de l'électorat
majoritaire
alors croyez vous qu au lendemain d'une
seconde expression majoritaire de
l'opinion publique
ils rompent rompt le contrat qui les
lient à leurs électeurs je suis
convaincu du contraire
ainsi je vois bien sur mon écran de
télévision cette émission du club de la
presse n'est pas encore totalement
terminée noël copains compte sur vous
pour nous résumer la suite des propos du
chef de l'état et du candidat avis
carnet bien oui daniel nous venons
seulement depuis quelques minutes de
passer aux questions économiques c'est à
dire que toute la première heure de ce
club de la presse a été consacré
essentiellement aux questions proprement
politique le président de la république
ou plutôt le candidat a repris sur le
ton de la conversation parfois très
animée et sous une forme plus ramassé
plus concise l'essentiel des arguments
qu'il a développé tous ces jours ci à
travers ses meetings en france par
exemple consacre cause des par exemple
en ce qui concerne ses concurrents il a
dit il n'y a pas qu'un seul candidat
anti vise car comme le prétend monsieur
georges marchais mais il ya neuf
candidats anti fils car ils ont tort de
me critiquer comme ils le font car les
français ont compris que les critiques
qui visait le président visait qui
visait le président je dis bien visait
également la france et visait aussi les
français conclusion je suis le seul
dit-il à défendre et les français et
s'agissant du temps d'antenne elle
pendant la campagne officielle à la
télévision et la radio il a cette
formule 90% du temps de parole sera
utilisé par la critique à propos des
sondages un confrère lui faisant
observer que ces sondages étaient
peut-être pour lui inquiétant monsieur
giscard d'estaing a répondu regardez moi
est ce que j'ai l'air de quelqu'un à
d'inquiets quelques indications
concernant l'avenir
en ce qui concerne la nomination du
premier ministre chaque chose en son
temps mais dit monsieur giscard
d'estaing il faudra tenir compte des
indications fournies par l'élection
présidentielle elle-même et s'agissant
des réformes
monsieur giscard d'estaing at il
abandonné ce thème réformateur du début
de son septennat
eh bien il répond là
qu'il entend développer des réformes
dans deux directions d'abord le poids de
la bureaucratie et de l'administration
qui pèse sur la france est second devant
le thème de l'éducation il s'agit de
retrouver dit il une école qui
représente l'unité culturelle de la
société française vous le voyez nous
sommes ramenés à ce thème de l'unité
qu'il a développée dans l'extrait
qu'elle vous avez entendu tout allait
bien si noël monsieur mitterrand était
lui à dijon où il a une nouvelle fois
cet après-midi essayer de rassembler et
d'élargir son électorat
reportage bernard pradines haut et jean
françois renaud de dijon les cibles de
monsieur mitterrand dans son discours de
dijon cet après-midi la politique
étrangère du gouvernement actuel elle
manque de dignité
le vote des français à l'étranger du
trucage l'information le pouvoir en
abuse
ses arguments une autre politique
économique pour sauver l'emploi le droit
à l'alternance enfin un élan national
autour de lui je pense aussi à celles à
ceux qui ont grandi depuis ou payer ceux
qui n'avaient pas d'engagement politique
ce qu'elle n'avait pas 18 ou 20 ans ils
sont des millions à celle ci est à cela
je dit dépêchez vous de venir nous
rejoindre
il paraît qu'il ya des querelles des
disputes des compétitions d'état-major
il paraît que au travers des réunions
publiques
on s'adresse à moi ou aux autres
socialistes sur un ton qui ne serait pas
tout à fait ta mittal tout cela m'est
égal ce qui compte c'est la réalité
populaire
je souhaite oui je souhaite que nous
puissions mettre les pins dans les pas
de la grande aventure de la grande
entreprise qui rassemblait ses foules
qui nous attendent encore et que nous
verrons autour de nous le 26 avril le 10
mai pour assurer dans l'entousiasme vous
rassurer le gouvernement de la france
monsieur krivine qui faute d'avoir
obtenu les 500 parrainages n'est pas
candidat appelle à voter au premier tour
pour les candidats ouvriers sans donner
non et au second tour pour le candidat
de la gauche le mieux placé à la marie
france garaud contre l'accroissement
permanent illimitée et sans discernement
de la couverture sociale propos
recueillis par le quotidien du médecin
madame garraud qui se prononce en faveur
d'un ticket modérateur de 50 % seulement
pour le petit risque de maladies
situation relativement calme au liban
aujourd'hui aussi bien beyrouth
qu'autour de la ville chrétienne de sa
relais au nord du liban sur le plan
politique par contre le conseil national
palestinien réunis à damas a ouvert ses
travaux en présence du président syrien
hafez el-assad est en avance bien sûr de
monsieur yasser arafat
à paris le ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean françois poncet
a convoqué lui les ambassadeurs de
france
intéressé par ce problème du liban pour
une séance de travail dont on connaîtra
les résultats demain matin à beyrouth
enfin le premier ministre libanais a
tenu à rappeler qu'aucune initiative
américaine française ou internationale
ne devait être entreprise sans l'accord
des autorités officielles libanaises ce
qui est d'ailleurs le sentiment du
gouvernement français
véritables journées et nuits d'émeutes
qui fabrique stone dans la banlieue sud
de londres bilan 200 blessés dont 165
policiers de nouveaux affrontements ont
repris d'ailleurs il y à deux heures
environ
ces quartiers de la grande banlieue de
la capitale anglaise sont en majorité
habité par des noirs treppoz à ce
problème économique s'ajoute donc celui
du raciste une enquête de jean marc qui
nous allons racisme en grande banlieue
un commando d'extrême droite descend en
garde louis chamla plusieurs employés
noirs sont roués de coups
c'était un 19 octobre à 15 heures
l'un d'eux m'a frappé à la hauteur des
yeux avec un sou qui contenait une
solution démoniaque et le liquide a
coulé dans les yeux pourquoi vous
ont-ils fait ça c'est leur passion de
pensée pour les noirs n'ont rien à faire
ici
comment réagissez vous aujourd'hui
ça m'a complètement changé je vivre
perpétuellement dans la peur quand je
marche dans la rue j'ai peur quand je
suis à mon travail j'ai peur c'est parce
qu'elle vit en permanence dans ce climat
de peur et de méfiance que deux mois
après l'incendié toujours inexpliqué qui
a fait ici treize victimes
l'immense majorité de la communauté
noire de louis cham reste persuadé qu'il
ne s'agissait pas d'un accident mais
qu'elle a été encore une fois la victime
d'un crime raciste
alors pour protester je cite contre les
lenteurs de l'enquète d'une police dont
il se méfie contre le silence glacé du
gouvernement et l'indifférence de la
presse plus de 5000 résidants noir de
lewisham sont venus faire entendre leur
voix début mars en plein coeur de
londres pour faire savoir à tous que
derrière le fait divers se cache trop
souvent le raciste
comme m
russell profite 34 ans professeur et
conseiller municipal travailliste de
l'eau et cham issue de cette nouvelle
génération noir qui commence à peine à
accéder aux fonctions électives
il est sans cesse l'objet de menaces
anonymes un climat de tension qui
l'attribuent d'abord au chômage deux
fois plus fort chez les noirs avec cette
récession
certains blancs valeur entre les noirs
responsable de l'aggravation de la
situation économique et les plus
racistes et d'entre eux du moins ceux
qui le sont ouvertement s'efforcent
d'exploiter cette peur du lendemain en
créant un climat de tension entre les
races la grande-bretagne britannique
tenez car à 10 maçon au chômage et
membre du front national organisation
raciste et l'extrême droite le front ne
compte que quelques milliers de membres
en grande bretagne nostalgique du
nazisme ou partisans du coup de poing il
affirme défendre leur pays
nous avons peur de la communauté noire
sur cent sept mille habitants à lewisham
il y à 35000 noir l'émigration nous fait
peur dans ce quartier nous sommes déjà
encerclé
ces watts quelles solutions demandez
vous la seule solution c'est qu'ils
rentrent chez eux
vous savez pourtant que la plupart sont
sujets britanniques
ce n'est pas mon problème
une déclaration qui n'est pas du goût de
ceux passant ni de celui des
contre-manifestants d'extrême-gauche que
la police ici va expulser avant que les
choses ne tournent à l'aigre
comme c'est souvent le cas pendant les
matchs de football
car c'est d'abord là que
l'extrême-droite s'efforce de recruter
de plus en plus les noirs évite les
stades
il ya eu trop de bagarres raciale le
royaume uni compte deux millions de gens
de couleur
- 2 4 % de la population globale mais
40% d'entre eux ne sont pas des immigrés
ils sont nés en grande-bretagne
pakistanais indiens ou jamaïcain comme
ici à lowery cham
ils vivent dans les faubourgs dortoir et
c'est là bien sûr que se pose le
problème de leur cohabitation avec la
population blanche
la famille prennent leur gosse tu n'as
que les voisins noir c'est vrai monsieur
et madame train de regarder son temps
devient avec leurs voisins immédiats
mais l'avenir
leur part est précaire j'ai des amis qui
me disent si on reste les bras croisés
de même seront en minorité tout le pays
sera noir vous savez on sait très bien
qu'ils attaquent les vieux la sortie du
foyer hélas les faits sont les faits la
plupart des agressions sont commises par
des jeunes noirs dans cette atmosphère
d'inquiétude croissante
la police se retrouve seule au premier
rang pour remplir une mission à laquelle
elle est encore peu préparé ce n'est que
récemment que le gouvernement lui a
officiellement ordonner d'enquêté sur la
violence raciste dans cette école du
nord de londres on parle plus de 10
langues fils d'émigrants turc aux grecs
aux toits les enfants de ces
britanniques de souche indienne par
exemple que le marché du travail avait
accueilli à bras ouverts dans les années
ceux là même dont on s'efforce désormais
de freiner l'entrée au royaume uni parce
que la grande-bretagne découvre
lentement aujourd'hui qu'il lui est
difficile de conjuguer démocratie et
société multiraciale à londres réunion
des ministres des finances et des
gouverneurs de banques centrales des
cinq pays les plus industrialisés du
monde etats unis grande bretagne france
japon et allemagne fédérale au centre de
débats lé taux d'intérêt du crédit dans
ces différents pays taux très élevé pour
le moment qui freinent l'investissement
des entreprises ne faut pas l'attendre
de résultats très spectaculaire de cette
première réunion
faits divers 24 heures après la
libération de la petite sylvie à paris
les enquêteurs ne disposent d'aucun
élément nouveau
des voisins un moment soupçonnée ont été
mis hors de cause cette fois les
policiers pensent et sont même
pratiquement sûr que les ravisseurs
habite tout de même dans un périmètre
très limité aux alentours de l'immeuble
où habite la petite sylvie il est un
tiercé cet après midi
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 5 le 3
et le 1 dans l'ordre de préférence
ça ne rapporte pas gros mais tout de
même mille 40 francs pour 5 francs dans
l'ordre et dans un ordre différent
toujours pour 5 francs deux cent huit
cent mille 40 francs 210 francs
et puisque c'est dimanche si je vous
invitais à danser pour terminer à danser
au palace la boîte à la mode de paris
vous en avez sans doute beaucoup entendu
parler et même si vous n'avez pas envie
d'y aller vous allez savoir ce qui s'y
passe avec ce reportage de pierre faut
notre danseurs journalistes
or la visconti se mélangent dans
l'inconscient de la fête au coeur de la
nuit les noms célèbres les plus anonymes
c'est peut-être cela le succès du polar
la chine est amusant
mais à vivre la nuit j'aime bien vivre
palace mais nuit notamment à brice et
mer le nouveau grand prêtre de la nuit
dit qu'il vend un produit snob à un
public populaire il pourrait rajouter
qu'il vend un public snop un produit
populaire et ça marche
l'essentiel n'est pas là c'est tout le
monde parce que je tiens beaucoup à ce
que je ferai tout le monde parce qu'on
ne devons nous pas que que a invité les
gens à l'entrée latérale et basques un
théâtre va être un lieu qui donc le
palace est à chaque soir près de 1500
personnes se bousculent pour parader
chacun ici et star et devient star trini
la crise et le quotidien d angoisse
c'est le monde de la fête pour certains
c'est la décadence
pour d'autres c'est le merveilleux
quel pas là c'est un lieu relativement
mondain ont rencontré d'autres comme pas
qu'ils n'auraient copains de copains
léman
les
le à la fenêtre du plaisir et à la bonne
étoile certain intérêt
au coeur du palace en sous sol et une
boîte restaurant très fermé qui a pour
nom il vivait c'est une des bonnes idées
de fabrice et mer puisque tout le monde
se bouscule pour obtenir la carte très
select du saint des saints et soirée
privée à nîmes le nouveau coeur de la
nuit parisienne
ce jour là par exemple on fêtait en même
temps que le troisième anniversaire du
palace la fin du salon du prêt à porter
l'ancien théâtre palace est bel et bien
mort un nouvel endroit nocturne et celui
de la fête et de les priver quelqu un là
au passage exposition modigliani au
musée d'art moderne de la ville de paris
jusqu'au 28 juin louis doucet s'est
attaché à faire revivre cette grande
figure de montparnasse modigliani dont
la légende vous allez le voir ne
correspond pas forcément à la vérité
regardons les choses ce qui frappe dans
cette exposition c'est que presque tous
les portraits les yeux vides alors un
pain de mie qui supprime le regard de ce
deal plein ne cherche-t-il pas à tuer
quelque chose à l'intérieur de lui même
et dans ce cas que signifie l'excusent
de l'alcool et de la drogue
le pauvre patron de sphinx était alors
tous à partir de cela
j'enchaîne sur la question quelle est la
réelle valeur de cette auréole de héros
romantique tracy autour de la tête du
jeune du romain dit voici la réponse de
la propre fille du peintre est jeanne
hébuterne elle s'appelle comme son père
jeanne modigliani
je n'ai jamais souffert là à cette
histoire de soutenir la fin je dis
comment antilles dont le plus des 4 le
plus trivial
ensuite il a toujours reçu des secours
de sa famille c'est quand il faut sauver
le show du mandat de ça mais ils peuvent
le voir plutôt que de manger c'était
comment faire sans l'avait empêché de
prendre derrière comme taladro que ben
j'ai dû acheter tout le monde enfin ou
de lock up je crois que quand il avait
de l'argent à cette époque c'était si
c'est l'opium
mais citez moi un seul fait d'un seul
écrivain de cette génération qui n'est
pas finie l'opium de remarques
premièrement ça ne l'a pas empêché de
faire la peinture plus s'aimer
deuxièmement le contraire est vrai aussi
savoir qui n'est pas nécessaire d'être
alcoolique ou trop gay pour faire un
grand pas
en vérité faut-il chercher une morale à
cette histoire sinon qu'une fois la
légende installée elle est bien
difficile à retoucher difficile parce
que le génie est clos dans la souffrance
est encore disons le assez conforme à
guider bourgeoise de l'artiste maudit
dont l'oréal un peu sulfureuse et tout
compte fait ce plaisante
jusque là tout bien entendu sa lippe
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
ensemble venant de collections du monde
entier réunis alors outre se mérite
il en a un autre tenter d'arracher
modigliani a tout un cinéma de mauvaise
littérature pour le rampant entièrement
à la peinture
et croyez-moi cela ce range dans la
catégorie des bonnes actions
à
la météo maintenant pour terminer demain
la plus grande partie du pays
bénéficiera d'un temps toujours agréable
avec l' alternance de passages nuageux
et d'éclaircies toutefois sur le quart
sud ouest du pays le temps sera orageux
et de fréquentes averses se produiront
en fin d'après midi les nuages seront
également abondant en matinée au nord de
la loire mais suivi d'éclaircies
l'après-midi un rafraîchissement
sensible se produira sur la moitié nord
de la france
voilà les prochains rendez vous de
l'information c'est d'abord le dernier
journal en fin de programme avec
pierre-alain demain antennes de midi on
saura toujours dans l'espace avec l'un
astronomes monsieur antoine labeyrie et
puis demain soir je vous rappel après le
journal à 20h35 ou à 2h01 horaires un
petit peu différent raison de la
campagne électorale mais enfin tout de
suite après le journal et la campagne
officielle sur antenne 2 vous aurez le
magazine question de temps présentée par
jacques à bouchard le thème de ce
question tant le nouveau défi asiatique
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur antenne 2 bonsoir